[Music]
on this tuesday night critical aid
in a crisis when an opportunity comes to
help your own country
you know i'll raise my hand for that
newfoundland and labrador
lends a hand to ontario sending a team
of doctors and nurses
the first reported death in canada
linked to the astrazeneca vaccine
it's really unfortunate and we need to
be very clear about that plus ontario
and ottawa fight over paid sick leave
and the province-wide lockdown looming
over nova scotia
canada's tax deadline creeps closer the
complications and how to get a refund
sooner and a novel idea
started with one line and then
we just kept going how lockdown inspired
a labor of love
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with efforts by one of canada's
smallest provinces to help canada's
biggest get through a crushing third
wave of kobit 19.
newfoundland and labrador is sending
reinforcements to ontario's overburdened
hospitals
a team of nine doctors and nurses
boarded a military plane this morning
bound for ontario among them dr allison
fury
wife of newfoundland and labrador
premier andrew fury
they're expected to start working
tomorrow at toronto hospitals
ontario certainly needs help and though
this team isn't big enough to turn the
tide it is a
practical decent and neighborly thing to
do when others are in crisis
eric sorenson has our top story tonight
the cavalry has arrived
three doctors and six nurses from
newfoundland and labrador to be deployed
in toronto area hospitals
among the team members the premier's
wife who's an emergency physician
i will be in a covid ward
in one of the hospitals so actively
caring for
patients with covet 19. the canadian
armed forces are also assigning nine
icu nurses and up to three medical
assistance teams to help
the need so great in ontario that beds
in big tents are now in use
outside sunnybrook hospital sending men
and women in uniform to help in ontario
is a serious step we're doing this
because the situation requires it as in
previous waves of the pandemic ontario
doctors are prepared and trained to
decide who gets critical care
but it's not like a train crash says one
doctor where everyone needs help the
same day
there is optimism hospitals will not
have to triage
critically ill patients when you're
getting a thousand critical care
patients spread over the course of
weeks which we are here then there is an
opportunity to to adapt the system
and grow capacity and there is reason
for optimism in ontario's brutal third
wave
the average in new daily cases passed
two thousand a month ago
three thousand on april eighth four
thousand on the fourteenth and peaked at
almost forty four hundred april
seventeenth
but it has trended lower since then the
seven day average today
fell below four thousand for the first
time in two weeks
hospitalizations and icu cases continue
to rise
but could start to level off in a couple
of weeks if we're careful i think we
have to continue
to make sure we don't relapse and go
back into a state where we don't have
enough
health care facilities to take care of
these patients for now
ontario is getting much needed help from
newfoundland and labrador
where people have a history of lending a
hand it's just the way that that
newfoundlanders are
they are giving to their communities
both locally
and in their own country and abroad a
heartening gesture from a small province
to the biggest
eric sorensen global news toronto
last week ontario premier doug ford
promised his government would finally
set up a paid sick leave program which
essential workers desperately need
he claimed it would be the best program
anywhere in north america bar
none well today we did get a bit more
information but ontario is not launching
its own
program it wants to piggyback on a
federal one and ford's promise is
turning into a bit of a political fight
global's queen's park bureau chief
travis danraj is with me from toronto
travis what is going on with this
that is a question that so many
essential workers in this province
really
want the answer to right now donna and
this has been a political football paid
sick days
for months now the premier really not
wanting to budge
on this issue until as you said last
week on thursday when he promised that
this would be the best
program in north america so the
expectations were fairly high
for what this program would be well the
only plan that exists
right now as far as we know is for the
province to top up the federal program
with an additional
five hundred dollars for essential
workers for a total of
one thousand dollars a week now my
sources tell me
that that is a non-starter that the
federal government has already let the
province know that
and that they say that that is a
logistical nightmare now
deputy prime minister christopher's
office put out a statement today
and that reads in part when ontario is
ready to mandate sick leave in
provincially regulated businesses
as we have done for federally regulated
businesses we will be there to help
now the prime minister was asked about
all of this today here's what justin
trudeau said
we are there to help canadians we have
people's backs
we need to work together and provinces
need to look at the way to deliver
a sick leave through directly through
employers which the federal government
can't do
so travis does this get essential
workers any closer to a paid sick leave
plan in ontario
it doesn't at least not for right now
there is no timeline in place
and the later minister here in ontario
was asked about what
an alternative plan is he didn't really
have any clarity on that
and this really brings into question the
safety
of workers going to work who don't have
a choice to stay home
the leader of the opposition assessed
where we are right now as a province
to suggest that we we have time to wait
i just can't believe
that the government think that it's okay
to continue to drag their feet
while people's lives are literally
hanging in the balance
completely irresponsible uh it's
despicable
and they have to stop this political
back and forth
now this all comes in the backdrop of
the third state of emergency
in this province and also as the
canadian armed forces get set to come
on the ground here in ontario once again
donna
all right travis danraj in toronto thank
you
quebec is reporting the first death in
canada linked to the astrazeneca vaccine
a woman in her 50s died after developing
a rare vaccine-induced blood clot in her
brain
quebec officials have no plans to change
their vaccine strategy though saying the
benefits of the vaccine still
far outweigh the risks from covet 19.
our mike armstrong is following this
story for us tonight mike
well donna the quebec government only
got confirmation that a blood clot
was the cause of death at noon today
that confirmation
came from a laboratory in hamilton
ontario
the announcement came in quebec city
made by the province's public health
director
the woman who died was 54 years old and
lived in the montreal region
if we knew that she was going to do it
we would not give her the vaccine but
it's
impossible but i don't regret because
we are sure we are preventing more
deaths and more complications of the
disease
even with that vaccine quebec has opened
up the astrazeneca vaccine to
anyone between 45 and 79 years old
so far it's administered about four
hundred thousand doses now going in it
knew the chances of complications
due to blood clots was about one in one
hundred thousand
the health minister says that's right
about where quebec is
right now so far so far within four
hundred thousand
of astrazeneca we have less than four
cases so we are within those numbers so
it's really unfortunate and we need to
be very clear about that
but i think that's the price to pay to
be vaccinated
and to be going back to a normal life at
one point in time
the government is not changing the
vaccination protocols
since this death they say they're always
watching the numbers for complications
quebec has so far vaccinated about 33
percent of the province with at least
one dose
the goal is to hit 75 percent by june
24th
the national holiday here in quebec
donna
okay mike armstrong in gatineau quebec
tonight thanks
nova scotia announced a strict new
two-week lockdown today after three
consecutive days of record high covid19
cases
we're in a different situation than we
were a year ago covet variants require
us to act faster
be firmer and have a broader reach
starting tomorrow schools will be closed
all indoor non-essential services will
be shut down
indoor facilities like gyms and pools
will also close
another 96 new coveted cases were
reported in nova scotia today
the variants are spreading faster than
ever before the federal government is
deploying 60 members of the canadian
armed forces to assist at covid19
testing centers in nova scotia and in
alberta people are being warned there is
now an unprecedented risk of covid19
infection
in the province today alberta's test
positivity rate hit a record
11.4 percent more than 20
700 people are infected the hardest hit
region per capita is the municipality of
wood buffalo home to fort mcmurray
and the oil sands prime minister justin
trudeau says canada will send 10 million
dollars through the canadian red cross
to the indian red cross to help that
country
cope with a record-setting number of
covid19 infections
the official death toll from covet in
india will soon surpass 200 000.
the world health organization warns the
rush of people gathering at overburdened
hospitals
may be making the situation worse
allowing the virus to spread
even further redmond shannon reports
sitting at the hospital gates it's as
close as many indians with covert 19
are getting to medical help right now
and my father is in a very critical
condition i'm getting no help
numbers are given there but nobody is
responding numbers are not reachable
please help me please my father is dying
i can't
afford another loss i yesterday i lost
my younger brother
trains carry oxygen trucks around the
country
it's too late for some and it's not
enough to feed this spiraling demand
charities ration the precious gas others
find it on the black market dr alex
patel is battling covid in toronto
area hospitals his uncle suryakant who
likely
has coveted struggled to find a hospital
in western india
when you start to hear that hospitals
are running out of oxygen which if you
run out of oxygen
you know you're going to be unable to
care for even the most basic copic
patient who comes into hospital
you get very concerned niraj walia in
surrey bc
worries his elderly mom risks getting
covered
if she ventures out to get the vaccine
it's very concerning it's very
concerning for me right now
and i'm full with the stress with the
help of international community
i think that's the only way um to fix it
otherwise it's going to be spread
to whole world more international aid
arrived in india tuesday
as a russian firm says it wants to ship
one million vials of an
anti-viral drug morning everyone prime
minister justin trudeau says canada will
send medical supplies too
plus 10 million dollars to the indian
red cross
this will support everything from
ambulance services
to buying more ppe locally
meanwhile india's neighbor pakistan has
deployed troops
to enforce covet 19 restrictions as the
trend in cases there
points in a similar disturbing direction
redmond shannon global news london
prime minister trudeau faced tough
questions again today over a disturbing
allegation against canada's former top
soldier
general jonathan vance it's the first
time trudeau has addressed the issue
since last week's testimony from a
former senior advisor revealed the prime
minister's chief of staff
knew about the allegation and knew it
involved personal misconduct
documents obtained by global news show
senior advisors were told the allegation
involved sexual harassment
as mike lucatura reports they also
challenged trudeau's suggestion today
that his office didn't know the details
nobody knew that it was a
me too complaint prime minister justin
trudeau again
insisted neither he his defense minister
nor his staff
knew the nature of a 2018 allegation
against former chief of the defense
staff general jonathan vance however
last week
elder marquez a former senior adviser to
the prime minister
told the commons committee he had an
inkling my
presumption was certainly that it could
be of a sexual nature and i
but i don't think i was actually given
that information specifically an email
from a senior bureaucrat at the time to
a redacted individual referenced quote
allegations of sexual harassment flagged
by the military ombudsman
the previous day the bureaucrat said at
committee the redacted individuals were
people in the prime minister's office
will the prime minister be honest with
this house
and with the women serving bravely in
our canadian armed forces
that he was aware and he failed them for
three years in response trudeau repeated
his government took the appropriate
actions when they found out about the
allegation
in 2015 when a complaint complaint came
forward
we forwarded that to the the privy
council office so that they
could do the follow-up necessary but
unfortunately the ombudsman
was not able to reveal the full extent
because he didn't have permission
but there remain questions about who
knew what
marquez testified last week trudeau's
chief of staff katie telford
was in the loop on the file tuesday
trudeau leapt
to her defense katie's leadership on
this every step of the way
is why we call ourselves a famous
feminist
government and why we will continue to
look to do more the government has
promised an independent investigation
into the allegations of sexual
misconduct in the military and three
months after our reporting
first brought this to light senior
sources tell global news
an announcement is expected within the
next week or two
mike lacouter global news ottawa
caught on camera coming up the violent
arrest of a woman with dementia and how
police
joked about it
[Music]
there's another troubling story about
police use of force this one involving a
woman with dementia
the 73 year old colorado woman was
forcibly arrested last june
karen garner wandered out of a walmart
store without paying for about 13
dollars worth of goods
the police body cam footage of her
arrest
is disturbing
an officer grabs her arms pushes her to
the ground and handcuffs her
she appears distressed and repeatedly
says she is going home
her lawyer says her shoulder was
dislocated her arm fractured
and her wrist sprained stand up i'm
not doing anything right now you're
resisting
later in this video from inside the
police station officers congratulate
each other on the arrest and laugh about
it as they review the video
one officer says here comes the pop as
the woman's shoulder
is dislocated karen garner's family is
suing the police alleging excessive
force and
accusing them of holding her for six
hours without medical help
they say her dementia has since worsened
one officer has been put on
administrative leave two others moved to
administrative duties
and a criminal investigation is underway
tax time the complications of filing
during a pandemic
friday's deadline for filing your taxes
is looming
new options new rules and new
circumstances mean millions of canadians
are faced with a more complicated tax
return this year
if you owe and don't file on time not
only could you be penalized there may be
a delay in receiving other much needed
benefits
as our senior business correspondent ann
gaviola explains
how and when you file is more important
than ever
2020 was a big adjustment for amanda
soriano the pandemic took a toll on her
wedding photography side business and
her full-time job became remote
i was excited for the first two weeks
and then as time went by i was kind of
missing the day-to-day interactions with
colleagues and essentially leaving the
house
ig wealth management says nearly half of
filers are making claims related to
working remotely this year
for many that's the new 400 work from
home tax break
so as long as you were working from home
for fifty percent of the time
um since last march two dollars a day
uh up to two hundred days so you can get
four hundred dollars in total
uh you can deduct that amount covid 19
relief benefits are a complicating
factor
impacting about 45 percent of filings
this year tax experts say many
recipients who owe money
haven't budgeted for it there's some
relief if your total taxable income in
2020 was 75 000
or less and you received at least one
covet 19 benefit
you automatically have a grace period on
interest for one year
but you still have to file by friday and
missing the deadline could delay a host
of other government payments from the
canada child benefit to tax credits
and recovery benefits accountants are
under pressure too
especially at those smaller firms
struggling to keep up with new rules and
more paperwork
chartered professional accountants have
asked the federal government to extend
the deadline like they did last year but
ottawa said no
clients are having trouble getting
information to them
and they're doing a lot more work as
well because they've been helping
their clients apply for the wage and
rent subsidy and some of the other
assistance programs as well
so it's been a very difficult time for
them how you file is important too
last year 90 of filers did so online and
the cra says processing times for
electronic filings are three to five
days compared with 10 to 12
weeks for paper returns so if you can
file online it is recommended
ann gaviola global news toronto
up next how a love of literature helped
three women
write off the pandemic
during the first two waves of this
pandemic few places were more vulnerable
than long-term care homes
thousands of residents got sick and died
and those who survived endured months of
lockdown
well three women who live in long-term
care in calgary found a way to get
through
by turning to each other and their love
of literature
heather urex west has their story
at long-term care facilities around the
world
covid19 is having a devastating impact
from the outside the suffering and loss
of life is difficult to watch
for those living inside it's even harder
we couldn't see anybody it couldn't go
anywhere diana van giffen heather graham
and loretta scrotchings are residents of
care west garrison green
in calgary a long-term care facility
that accommodates
seniors and younger adults with
disabilities like them
graham's lived here for eight years she
has
ms but a sharp mind and an active social
circle
that is until kovit 19 shut everything
down
at certain times there were some of the
staff that had come down with kovid
and so we had to be all tested and then
we had to stay in our rooms for 14 days
cut off from family and friends and
unable to leave the women took comfort
in each other
and a shared love of books from our book
club
we had an idea that well we would like
to try writing the book
with the help of a recreational
therapist the trio began writing
together in
2018 unaware that the fictional world
they were creating would become
a place of refuge and escape from the
frightening reality
that would surround them soon i really
think it did help us with the pandemic
because
like we we had something to focus
ourselves on
it's why book three written in 2020
is a lot longer than the previous tales
it started with one line
and then we just kept going
the mysteries set in a fictional town
near prince rupert bc
are now available on amazon but the
women hope the trilogy
tells another story too it gave us a
chance to show that we're not just
wasting away here
long-term care isn't the end and you
still you get to live
vaccinated now and ready to see what
their next
chapters will bring heather eurex west
global news
calgary and that is global national for
this tuesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is one for the
books it's the first super moon of 2021
it's called a pink super moon
named after the pink phlox wildflower a
full moon won't be this close to the
earth and this bright for another month
so try to get a look at it if you can
thanks for watching
take care of yourselves bye
[Music]
you